puisque vous parlez de ce nouveau
souffle à gauche cela s'inscrit dans un
rassemblement on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste je
ne souhaite pas que dès maintenant on
nous dit il et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit de présenter votre candidature de
quel droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
ça laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français soit de
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 5 avril ni dîner
clandestins luxueux à paris la polémique
ne cesse d'enfler depuis la diffusion
d'un reportage vendredi dernier sur m6
les soirées payantes sans masque ni
gestes barrière est peut être en
présence de ministres
le parquet de paris a en tout cas ouvert
une enquête alors y at il une france au
dessus des lois ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir moscou assure que
ses récents mouvements de troupes et de
matériel près de la frontière avec
l'ukraine ne sont pas une menace
l'europe elle exprime sa grande
inquiétude et assure que kiev à son
soutien indéfectible le chef de la
diplomatie européenne s'entretiendra
avec son homologue ukrainien et des 27
ministres des affaires étrangères de
lieu lors d'une réunion au cours du mois
d'avril alors toujours après des mois de
tension en méditerranée orientale elle
est prête à renouer le dialogue avec la
turquie
les présidents de la commission et du
conseil de
seront à ankara demain il sera question
des réfugiés
ce week-end athènes a accusé les
garde-côtes tueur de provocation à leurs
proches d'encourager les migrants à se
rendre dans les eaux territoriales de la
grèce
[Musique]
la france métropolitaine confiné depuis
samedi soir et pour une durée de quatre
semaines au minimum pas de quoi
refroidir fois pires a priori les
organisateurs et convives de dîners
clandestins la polémique est partie d'un
reportage de m6 en immersion diffusé le
2 avril dans un lieu présenté comme un
restaurant clandestins ou client et
serveur ne porte pas de masque et où les
gestes barrières semblent un lointain
souvenir
pour plus de précisions on retrouve en
direct estelle farges en direct de la
rue de montmartre à paris dans le centre
de la capitale bonsoir estelle quels
sont les derniers développements de
cette affaire ce soir eh bien écoutez
c'est fanny une enquête a été ouverte
par le procureur de la république rémy
est seul a été confiée à la brdp
la brigade de répression de la
délinquance à la personne de la police
judiciaire de paris une enquête pour
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui et
travail dissimulé
objectif vérifier l'exactitude des frais
rapportés dans le reportage de nos
confrères aide m6 et éventuellement
poursuivre organisateurs et participants
leur excellent l'un des organisateurs
présumés avait dans ce reportage affirmé
que des ministres en participer ces
dîners haut de gamme avant de se
rétracter
et oui stéphanie alors d'abord cet homme
il a été identifié par plusieurs médias
est interloqué après la diffusion du
reportage il s'agit de jean-pierre un
chalencon collectionneurs personnalité
médiatique est aussi propriétaire du
palais libyenne à paris alors cet homme
par le biais de son avocat il reconnaît
implicitement être l'une des sources du
reportage est d m6 et en ce qui concerne
ces fameux a dîné avec les ministres et
bien il plaide l'humour et le sens de
l'absurde ce sont elles les mots
utilisés dans le communiqué en d'autres
termes ses propos sur ses prétendues
dîner avec des ministres était une
blague et celle cette blague
en tous les cas tout de même fait réagir
la classe politique
et oui à commencer par marlène à chapet
à la ministre déléguée à la citoyenneté
a déclaré que si des ministres ou des
députés avaient participé à de telles
dîner clandestins il faudrait qu'il soit
fait la mise et comme n'importe quel
citoyen ce à quoi une internaute a
répondu qu'il fallait qu'il démissionne
suggestions approuvé par marlène
schiappa sur twitter de son côté l
gérald darmanin plaide pour des
poursuites et condamnations si les faits
sont avérés le ministre de l'intérieur à
qui a précisé aussi que la règle est la
même pour tous même dans les beaux
quartiers de paris
fin de citation pour remercier celle
farges en direct de la rue montmartre
dans le centre donc de paris alors les
organisateurs les convives quel qu'il
soit se croit-il
au dessus des lois y at-il la france des
privilèges et l'autre france pour autant
et on arrivait au bout de
l'acceptabilité des français faut-il les
blâmer place à notre décryptage avec nos
invités
[Musique]
prix pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric jeanjean restaurateurs
secrétaire général de l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
des bouches du rhône bonsoir frédéric
jeanjean merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés nicolas vidal éditorialise bonsoir
nicolas vidal
enfin arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être là
donc des dîners un montant qui serait
organisée à paris dans des restaurants
clandestins en pleine pandémie n'en
fallait pas plus pour mettre le feu aux
poudres vous qui est refermée depuis des
mois frédéric jeanjean comment vous
recevez cette information déjà ce que
nous entendons c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un restaurant traditionnel puisqu'il
s'agit du palais libyenne domicile de
monsieur chalencon et que s'il s'agit
d'un club privé
donc ça c'est la première chose il est
évident que les soirées privées c'est ce
que nous dénonçons depuis près d'un an
avec la fermeture des discothèques
c'est ce que nous dénonçons aussi avec
la fermeture de nos établissements et
que nous n'avons eu de cesse de dire
qu'il vaut mieux que nous puissions
travailler avec un protocole strict
encadré et que l'on sache ce que l'on
fait plutôt que de laisser tout le monde
de fermer parce que la nature est en ce
qu'elle est on ne pourra pas empêcher
les gens de se regrouper et de se
retrouver et ou plus les temps qui vaut
ce qui viennent vont être agréable ou
être ensoleillé au plus de la voir ce
genre de manifestation de regroupement
c'est naturel c'est humain ça c'est la
première réflexion après qu'il s'agisse
de pierpoljak aux gens qui se retrouvent
on subit tous en ce moment cet effet il
faut qu'on soit tous solidaires ça c'est
la deuxième réflexion qui vient et est
en fait la véritable question que je
poserai ça fait un an que nous subissons
cet état de fait dans toute la france ça
fait un an qu'on nous dit que nous
subissons cela pour éviter que l'hôpital
de son intention
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis un an
pour éviter que l'hôpital ne soit en
tension et là on arrive sur un terrain
peu plus politique mais il faut quand
même vous poser la question est ce qu'on
est arrivé est ce qu'on a prévu
qu'il y ait ne passerelle qui soit
établie entre le public et le privé où
est-ce qu'on reste sur les diktats de
l'école de nantes l'école des hautes
études en santé publique qui veut que
signé que le public au coeur du public
point de salut est ce qu'on a prévu
quelque chose avec l'armée avec un
service de santé qui quand même assez
conséquent est ce qu'on a prévu
d'ouvertures de lits des formations de
personnel je sais pas en fait depuis un
an à long terme au début on comprenait
que ont été pris de court
le pilonnage qu'est ce qui a été proposé
on nous parle la vaccination est depuis
le début ça patine un peu ça tarde à
démarrer
alors là il ya aussi de l'agacement
arnaud benedetti alors c'est vrai que ce
qui fera pas évidemment dans ce
reportage
c'est forcément vendeur les soirées un
peu spécial caviar champagne les menus
allant de 260 ha à plus de 450 euros
mais il faut quand même être honnête
tout le monde sait en france qui a pas
que ce type de restaurant qui restent
ouverts il ya des bistrots beaucoup plus
modeste donc on va pas faire mine de
l'ignorer mais il n'empêche ça fait
désordre aujourd'hui en pleine polémique
alors que le gouvernement nous impose
des restrictions qui sont parfois
extrêmement compliqué à accepter ça va
laisser des traces alors on rappelle
qu'une enquête est en cours et qui a eu
un peu rétro pédalage on ne sait pas
encore si oui ou non des ministres y ont
assisté mais le mal est fait en tout cas
ça va laisser des traces dans l'opinion
avec déjà une vraie défiance envers les
pouvoirs publics ça va le faire que
renforcer un sentiment qui existe depuis
longtemps ce qui n'est pas lié
d'ailleurs à la crise sanitaire mais que
la crise sanitaire peut-être à travers
ce type d'image ne fait qu'accentuer il
y à une défiance aujourd'hui vis-à-vis
des élites vers le visa ville du haut de
la société toutes les études d'opinion
depuis maintenant un certain nombre
d'années montrent que les françaises et
les français considèrent qu' il y a
disons deux poids deux mesures
qui existent dans la société française
avec des élites sociales économiques
politiques qui serait dit on voit de
sécession par rapport au reste de la
société d'ailleurs c'est une réalité
objective aussi quand on regarde un
certain nombre en certain nombre de
chiffres il suffit de voir par exemple
que à paris aujourd'hui 45 48% des
cadres supérieurs habite paris alors
qu'il n'ya plus que 9 % d'ouvriers donc
cette réalité de la sécession social
c'est un phénomène sociologique qui
toute façon était inscrit profondément
aujourd'hui malheureusement dans la
société française des images de ce type
le fond que leur enfoncer dans un pays
qui a subi une crise comme celle des
gilet jaune qui a été une crise
politique profondément marqué par un
sentiment anti élites
on voit bien que ce à quoi nous avons
assisté à travers ce reportage c'est le
sentiment qui se défera denis frac que
les contraintes sanitaires ne seraient
pas les mêmes pour toutes les portes
plus donc les dégâts existait déjà par
le passé ils ne seront vraisemblement
qu'un peu plus renforcé aujourd'hui
n'est plus ni moins mais ça entretient
s'il voulait à l'o2 de dissociation de
distance d'opposition par rapport aux
responsables quels qu'ils soient
avant de faire un gérant nicolas vidal
en face au tollé le parquet de paris on
l'a dit a ouvert une enquête beaucoup de
réactions politiques évidemment les
arrière pensées électorales sont
nécessairement à écouter celle de
bastien lachaud député de la france un
souvenir suivie de celle de florian
philippot dont la france d'en haut qui
vit sans masque où on va de déjeuner au
dîner clandestins ça rit à gorge
déployée devoir défoncé subir gentiment
les restrictions le problème n'est pas
tant eux le problème c'est notre
docilité collective face à eux la police
verbalise la jeunesse populaire quand
elle ne porte pas son masque mais les
puissants trinquent dont les restaurants
clandestins les pauvres et les étudiants
font la queue à l'aide alimentaire mais
la caste fait la fête dans ces soirées
privées qu'il dégage nicolas vidal
cette idée d'une france dans autres
serait au dessus des lois alors qu'on
nous fait la morale pour respecter les
restes gestes barrières et les
restrictions c'est ce qui va rester de
cette affaire même si peut-être qu'en
fait il n'y avait pas de ministre on
n'en sait rien les enquêtes nous nous
lira mais le mal est fait effectivement
c'est une politique pour moi qui ai
vraiment criant de 7,2 france et un an
bettina ne peut parler et le titre votre
émission le dis aussi mais pour moi vous
savez c'est finalement cette crise cette
polémique c'est finalement la crise du
coc vite 19 vécu d'un côté par les
élites kérosène vous savez les élites
kérosène sont chères à jean claude michy
cher et puis après vous avez la flemme
la fronde est déplorable christophe
guilluy vous avez forcément ça va faire
polémique à une défiance bien entendu
envers une classe duo ell et 1% ce qu'on
appelle le 1% les très aisés qui
finalement s'exonère de toutes les
règles sanitaires
on a vu de ce reportage de m6 la
question qui se pose est ce que c'est
une partie immergée de l'iceberg
ça c'est extrêmement important il ya ce
moment là les français finalement ils
acceptent de moins en moins bien de
tenir ensemble et certains les ripailles
encore ensemble
vous avez sûrement vu cette photo qui
vient de montpellier depuis précisément
de la plage de la grande motte
avec cette annonce qui a été dressé pour
des gens qui ont pris un peu l'air sur
la plage qui ont fait 400 euros pour que
mon port du masque et consommation avec
l'homme de dieu rosé dont vous imaginez
bien que ces exemples sont criants et
cette défiance eux continuent à monter
alors on comprend bien les jeux
politiques des uns et des autres mais
les français aujourd'hui sont au dessus
de ça et quand ça continue à
cristalliser cette crise de la défiance
de la démocratie finalement il ya ceux
qui font ce qu'ils veulent
et puis à les autres et puis il ya une
ombre d'okami j'appellerais ça la
gastronomie de l'endogamie bien entendu
c'est la bamboche d'une république
alternative qui se moque des règles et
en plus et en plus on verra ce que dit
l'enquète on verra les suites de cette
enquête
mais finalement on voit qu'elle est
gentil s'exonère des règles de l'état
donc ce que même l'état
ces règles sont bafoués et ça ça devient
insupportable arno bertina la part lev
et la crise des gis les jeunes c'est le
point de bascule effectivement de la
sédition d'une certaine partie desdites
française et c'est chose d'à finalement
on voit que c'est des restaurants ou
lors des clubs privés des dîners privés
il ya quand même des menus des tarifs
des recommandations des passe-droits des
digicodes donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
forme latente de ganic et ben ça va pas
remettre en place la confiance entre les
français qui galèrent
qui accepte de moins en moins bien vous
le savez les mesures sanitaires qui en
ont marre qui sont là qui peuvent pas
sortir piezo de la 19 heures et
maintenant que les associations 10 km on
imaginait que les français ils n'en
peuvent plus et que 30 seulement cette
polémique
elle va en fait et à l'est elles
caractérisent cette société fragmentée
fracturée voilà un peu mon sentiment sur
le premier frédéric jeanjean vont qui
connaissait voilà qui est au coeur du
réacteur c'est vrai que là voilà c'est
un peu facile et on va essayer de ne pas
tomber dans la facilité forcément c'est
de la provocation ces beaux endroits ces
tarifs exorbitants mais mais on le sait
en france que je disais en début de 2 de
ce débat il ya beaucoup bistrot qui
reste ouvert c'est une grande partie de
notre profession et ça évidemment ça
crée une disparité il ya les
restaurateurs qui respecte les règles
qui tirent la langue et ceux qui rient
d'eau fermé voilà ouvre dans l'ariège
l'arrière-garde si j'ose dire il y en a
beaucoup
alors écoutez si on a beaucoup je sais
pas parce qu'ils s'amendent pas
forcément ça c'est la première chose
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que je
fais quand même la différence entre les
clients qui vient de faire un bond de
boschaud par emilienne d'une part et
d'autre part le restaurateur qui est un
petit établissement qui parfois passe à
travers les mailles de la raquette au
pouvoir avoir les aident et qui se
trouvent obligés de trouver des
solutions pour pouvoir s'en sortir on
pouvoir bouffer pour payer son loyer
moi je des restaurateurs ici qui
arrivent ils travaillent pas un il faut
des plaintes portées du système d il y
en a qui ont résilié leur bail et ils
vivent dans le restaurant il ya des
restaurants où je rentre où vous avez
les lits et vous avez des gamins qui
jouent là au milieu alors s'il se
mettait à travailler à ouvrir moi je le
comprendrais tout à fait parce que y'a
un moment quand on est père ou mère de
famille et qu'on a des devoirs et qu'il
faut assumer
eh bien ça je le conçois tout à fait
vous savez c'est pas la première fois
que les gens se font attraper les
mouches au restaurant rappelez vous la
faire de du tribunal de la cour d'appel
de paris où plusieurs magistrats avaient
été pris en flagrant délit à table
rappelez-vous dans le canard enchaîné
cet article vous expliquer qu' il y
avait une
tables et les journalistes de bfm tv qui
s'étaient retrouvés avec en plus les
conseillers médicaux et scientifiques
qui venait d'expliquer qu'il fallait
loup fermé et respecter les gestes
barrières et qu'ils allaient manger dans
une arrière salle aussi donc vous avez
c'est pas nouveau mais je vous dis c'est
d'une manière générale c'est parce que
le fond du problème
qu'est ce qui a été fait pour que sorte
de cette situation où justement arnaud
benedetti sa pose bien sûr la question
de l'acceptabilité et c'est intéressant
les propos de frédéric jeanjean tout
d'abord avant de vous faire et j'ai
regardé ce sondage
ils datent d'il ya quelques jours plus
de sept français sur dix approuvent les
principales mesures annoncées par
emmanuel mais chrome alors ce qui est
rigolo c'est la deuxième partie de ce
sondage 1 près d'un français sur deux
46% et plus de six jeunes sur dix compte
transgresser les règles on trouve ça
super mémés ou comme pas vraiment les
appliquer ces règles
ça veut dire que dans le fond se fait
justice soi même on se dit bah écoutez
on nous voit là c'est un peu injuste on
les accepte pas donc on les transgresse
céreq tout simplement et puis on décide
d'aller au restaurant si on se sent pas
vraiment en danger
c'est ça le fond de cette affaire dans
toutes les situations qui relève des
circonstances exceptionnelles situations
de guerre mais les situations comme
celle que nous connaissons de crise
pandémie que nous assistons
nécessairement à des dérèglements
humains qui sont j'allais dire presque
malheureusement naturel ce qui est su il
ya toujours eu dans les guerres des
profiteurs de guerre c'est un grand
classique de l'histoire
là ce qui est intéressant dans ce
sondage c'est que il révèle au grand
jour ce phénomène assez contradictoire
c'est que il ya une majorité de français
qui approuvent
après 70 % les mesures qui ont été
prises par emmanuel macron pour ce
confinement qui ne dit pas son nom ce
confinement numéro 3 et puis vous avez
quasiment une majorité vous presque une
majorité de français qui est disposé à
l'est
transgresser est évidemment le la
deuxième la deuxième question qui est
importante parce que celle ci dit
véritablement quel est l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui d'une partie de l'opinion
publique qui considère que est la plus
vraisemblable le mans à subir les
conséquences d'une crise sanitaire
qu'elle fait les peaux dont elle fait
porter la responsabilité est parfois à
raison on enlevait fonctionnement de
l'état alors le virus bien évidemment
c'est une chose personne ne l'avait
prévu mais après la façon dont on
pouvait gérer ce virus là il ya
véritablement des questions qui se
posent sur la manière dont l'état a mis
en place sa politique salutaire pour
justement mettre fin à cette pandémie
les questions qui sont finalement les
questions essentielles celle du début de
la pandémie c'est à dire de mars dernier
ce restent les mêmes à ce stade vous
l'avez rappelé l'attention sur la
structure hospitalière pourquoi en
allant finalement n'avons pas nous
essayer de commencer à réarmer les
structures hospitalières pour faire face
pour faire face à des tensions à des
tensions salutaire la question des
moyens la question des logist la
logistique la question des vaccins
tous ces sujets viennent quand même
fortement infléchir l'acceptabilité des
françaises et des français qui
considèrent que finalement c'est leur
seule responsabilité personnelle ou voir
collective qui permettra de mettre fin à
cette pandémie rcv d'une certaine
manière il faut pas le nier non plus
mais en l'occurrence si vous voulez ce
qui apparaît quand même au grand jour
d'une grande partie de l'opinion
publique c'est que les solutions qu'il
aurait fallu mettre en place en termes
de gestion logistique organisationnelle
de moyens ne l'ont pas été bon en tout
cas suffisamment nicolas vidal il n'y a
pas de passe-droit tous les ministres
respectent la règle lundi bruno le maire
à l'issue de cette affaire
pensez vous que s'il est avéré que des
ministres et participer ça peut être là
la goutte d'eau
cela avec la mauvaise gestion de la
pandémie pour emmanuel macron avec des
répercussions en 2022
bien entendu le son si les ministres
s'ils enquête le dira on verra bien et
des tirs de barrage au twitter en ce
moment qui essaie de défendre les
ministres effectivement aussi des
ministres se trouvaient là dans ces
dîners privés
ces restaurants qu'un destin je ne sais
plus comment il faut les appeler il
faudra bien moment donné qu'il est en
dessus des sanctions et les démissions
bien entendu ça c'est important
mais pour rebondir cette question là
effectivement le voit depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire c'est une faillite de
l'état on l'a vu sur la logistique on
l'a vu sur les masques on l'a vu sur les
vaccins notamment est là et ensemble
bourbon piétine énormément sur les
vaccins et effectivement l'état
aujourd'hui ne peut plus rien faire de
plus en plus mal les choses et les
français effectivement ils vont faire un
peu comme bon leur semblent ils sont
lassés ils sont épuisés ils sont
entravés ils sont infantilisés ils sont
criminalisés donc aujourd'hui
effectivement face à l'impéritie de
l'état à gérer cette crise sanitaire et
je suis assez d'accord avec ça depuis le
20 ou le 16 mars 2020 encore nous avons
avancé monsieur jeanjean l'isère
nobility léger aussi en quoi nous avons
avancé finalement on se retrouve là donc
quand vous avez une impéritie tête de
l'état eh ben les gens moment donné on
appelle ça le gouvernement d âmes chacun
décide pour lui-même de sa
responsabilité à sortir on va pas sortir
et ça c'est extrêmement inquiétant parce
que rappelez-vous nous a appelé à
l'union nationale nationale la communion
tenir ensemble
rappelez vous ces campagnes de
communication effectivement aujourd'hui
tout ça est en train de se casser la
gueule pardonnez moi d'être un peu
triviale mais aujourd'hui ça pose
vraiment des problèmes et chaque jour
qui avance il ya des gens qui
transgresseront les règles dans tous les
côtés et ça pose vraiment le côté d'un
système de la nation comment on va
sortir cette rue et dans quel état on va
sortir cette crise sanitaire
et c'est une nouvelle fois j'insiste
dessus c'est l'émergence de cet état qui
est en faillite totale alors à grands
coups de plans de communication bien
entendu mais tout ça ne suffira pas et
la désespérance sociale deviendra vite
une bombe sociale pour les restaurateurs
et les cafetiers les commerçants et
toute une série de gens qui sont
aujourd'hui complètement hors sol et qui
sont vraiment complètement au sol par
rapport à cette crise là et on verra
bien comment on en sortira et la
question c est quand et dans quel état
nous en sortirons voilà face à des gens
arras et démunis et paupérisé un maximum
en tout cas
et sujets sont largement commentée sur
les réseaux sociaux ces dernières 48
heures les internautes qui ont même créé
des hashtag on veut les noms
frédéric jeanjean si il s'avère
justement des ministres aient participé
à ces dîners ça va changer les choses
pour vos collègues restaurateurs
il y aura peut-être une forme de de
révolte et on ne va plus obéir aux
règles et le faire finalement un visage
des masques et cette fois ci
écoutez on va voir parce qu'il faut
rester quand même responsable
avant toute chose dans cette période moi
simplement j'entendais tout à l'heure le
collègue intervenants qui disait que
c'est la faillite de l'état si on peut
attendre un petit peu parce que manuel
va croire dit que normalement le 15 mai
nous ouvrir et lyon alors si on peut
déclarer la faillite de l'état le 16 ou
le 17
elle ouvre le 15 et ça nous voit voilà
et va en tout cas c'est tout ce qu'on
vous souhaite sur les belles terrasses
dans le sud et ailleurs d'ailleurs on
espère récupérer le mot le beau temps à
cette même occasion merci frédéric
jeanjean nicolas vidal et arnaud
benedetti d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et flatte face à la
flambée de l'épidémie de kobe 19 les
écoles collèges et lycées de tout le
territoire ferment leurs portes pour eux
au moins trois à quatre semaines c'est
donc le grand retour de l'enseignement à
distance super pour quelque 12 millions
d'élèves une situation qui encore une
fois révèle les inégalités face à
l'enseignement à distance et le manque
d'anticipation du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
plus de détails avec mona amont dès lors
il y a comme un air de déjà vu le
casse-tête de l'enseignement distanti
elle est de retour et un an après
enseignants et élèves font à nouveau
face aux mêmes problématiques fracture
numérique ma logements par an dans
l'incapacité de surveiller la scolarité
de leurs enfants car ils travaillent
un an après le premier confinement et
l'histoire semble se répéter
notamment pour les élèves des milieux
ruraux ou défavorisés on retrouve
toujours les mêmes difficultés chez les
familles que l'an passé
le manque de matériel informatique
surtout chez les fratries
les connexions internet défaillante les
collectivités ont beau communiquer sur
les distributions qu'elles ont effectué
tous les problèmes sont loin d'être
réglés
il faut aussi étudier ce qui va être
proposé aux élèves en termes
pédagogiques
prise de court par les annonces du
président de la république les équipes
pédagogiques ont dû s'activer pour être
prête dès le mardi 6 avril afin de
préserver la fameuse continuité
pédagogique
ce nouveau confinement n'a pas été mieux
anticiper on se retrouve dans la même
situation d'urgence qu'il ya un an
c'est épuisant ce déni de réalité mais
du côté du ministère de l'éducation
nationale le ton se veut rassurant
quitte à ignorer les alertes jean michel
blanquer avait même affirmé fin août
dernier nous sommes préparés à tout mais
la réalité du terrain le contredit
encore une fois aujourd'hui
le ministre avait assuré que
l'institution scolaire avait les
ressources en ligne permettant d'assurer
une continuité pédagogique de qualité
alors que les professeurs se débrouille
avec les moyens du bord et tente de
développer des techniques d'enseignement
hybride
l'éducation nationale n'a toujours pas
mis en place des formations
d'enseignement à distance
aucun prof n'a eu de vraies formations
sur l'enseignement à distance qui pose
encore de nombreuses difficultés
on l'a encore vu récemment lorsque des
classes ont été fermées pour des cas de
kovy de 19 un enseignement à distance
qui pourraient être améliorées à l'aide
d'outils régulé par le ministère
la france a été l'un des derniers pays à
avoir fermé ses écoles face à la
troisième vague épidémique
alors que ces dernières semaines et les
syndicats d'enseignants clamer haut et
fort que le protocole sanitaire était
insuffisant jean michel blanquer a campé
sur ses positions
les écoles ne devait pas fermée pendant
ce temps et des milliers de classes
fermées face à la recrudescence de 99
encore une fois les chiffres
contredisent les slogans édulcorée de
l'éducation nationale selon santé
publique france on dénombré 34 mille
trois cents élèves du primaire et du
secondaire positif pour la seule journée
du 22 mars mais le ministère se défend
il a mis en place quelques ressources en
ligne avec une série de fiches publiés
sur son site eduscol le cned le centre
national d'enseignement à distance
propose de son côté un dispositif
complet et gratuit
mais si l'éducation nationale a bien
fourni quelques outils la réalité du
terrain reste la même un an après le
premier confinement pour les élèves et
les enseignants qui craignent un
décrochage scolaire il reste avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'ukraine moscou qui assure que ses
récents mouvements de troupes et de
matériel près de la frontière avec le
pays ne sont pas une menace
l'europe elle exprime sa grande
inquiétude et assure kiev de son soutien
indéfectible et puis direction la
turquie où les présidents de la
commission et du conseil de lieux seront
à ankara demain il sera question de
réfugiés avec le président et antoine
[Musique]
et
les trente ans que les cours sont
manipulés comment est-ce qu'on peut
réguler ça on ne peut pas c'est une
manipulation on va dire 2 0 la
possibilité de cette manipulation est
encore plus facile parce que vous avez
de nouveaux traders parce que vous avez
des gens qui ont été attirés par
l'argent assez facile le bitcoin
illustre quelque chose qui existe de
toute éternité gagner de l'argent en ne
faisant rien
en achetant un actif qui nous vaut
intrinsèquement rien grâce à des gogos
qui n'y comprennent rien sauf la
promesse de faire fortune qui en
profitent réellement ces manipulations
peau
malheureusement c'est pas les petites
sardines cd requinque le petit
particulier il est là pour ce faire
pondre
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous-même et
30 ans que les cours sont manipulés
comment est-ce qu'on peut réguler ça on
ne peut pas c'est une manipulation on va
dire 2 0 la possibilité de cette
manipulation est encore plus facile
parce que vous avez de nouveaux traders
parce que vous avez des gens qui ont été
attirés par l'argent assez facile le
bitcoin illustre quelque chose qui
existe de toute éternité gagner de
l'argent en ne faisant rien en achetant
un actif qui nous vaut intrinsèquement
rien grâce à des gogos qui n'y
comprennent rien sauf la promesse de
faire fortune qui en profitent
réellement de ces manipulations pour
malheureusement c'est pas les petites
sardines cd requinque le petit
particulier il a pour ce faire pour
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt francs si vous nous rejoignez l'union
européenne exprime sa grande inquiétude
et est sur l'ukraine de son soutien
indéfectible à face aux mouvements de
troupes russes près de ses frontières
kiev accusant moscou de masse et des
soldats au nord et l est le chef de la
diplomatie européenne s'entretiendra
avec son homologue ukrainien et les 27
ministres des affaires étrangères de
lieu lors d'une réunion en cours du mois
d'avril ce matin le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov s'est exprimé la
correspondance à moscou d'antoine
claireaux le porte-parole du kremlin a
été clair la russie n'est une menace
pour personne notamment l'ukraine et
reste simplement attentive à sa propre
sécurité
en attendant dans le donbass le
cessez-le-feu en vigueur toute la
deuxième moitié de 2020 n'est plus
respectée et le conflit fait de nouveau
des victimes
l'ukraine dénombre une vingtaine de ses
soldats tués depuis le début de l'année
mais de l'autre côté aussi il y à des
pertes en particulier parmi les civils
ainsi en république populaire de donetsk
un enfant de cinq ans a été tué chaque
mort surtout s'il s'agit d'un enfant est
une tragédie
c'est une tragédie tout cela est une
conséquence grade une situation qui n'a
pas été réglé et plus encore
la conséquence de l' escalade des
tensions sur la ligne de contact
malheureusement les accords ne sont pas
respectées
les responsabilités assumées auparavant
notamment par la partie ukrainienne ne
sont plus respectés de fait les échanges
de tirs peu contrôlées sont entamées et
ce sont des commandant des opérations
des forces armées ukrainiennes qui
prennent les décisions qu sur le terrain
sans obtenir une autorisation de leurs
supérieurs militaires
tout cela aggrave la situation l'attend
encore plus on en parle beaucoup
actuellement
vous le savez mais malheureusement à
l'heure actuelle nous ne voyons aucun
effort effectifs de la part de kiev
une critique qui vivent de nombreux
titres de presse ont en effet commenté
des mouvements de troupes en russie à
proximité de la frontière ukrainienne
on a aussi entendu joe biden ou encore
tout récemment le chef de la diplomatie
européenne apporté leur soutien sans
faille à l'ukraine mais on entend
rarement la position des autorités
locales du dombass qui sont pourtant en
première ligne et les principaux
concernés par cette hausse des tensions
je vous propose donc d'écouter comment
son vécu les événements du point de vue
du président de la république
autoproclamée de donetsk l'ukraine
continue de saboter ses négociations et
ne permet pas de faire en sorte qu'elle
se déroule comme prévu les pourparlers
au sein de tous les groupes sont bloqués
par conséquent nous ne voyons pas de
résultats bien entendu cela confirme que
le cren attise les tensions notamment
sur le plan médiatique en nous accusant
un moulin et la russie de préparer
quelque chose alors qu'en réalité ce
sont les forces armées ukrainiennes et
les décideurs de kiev kiis
table a mis ses menaces au bridge
octobre une chaîne youtube
on en revient donc toujours à la
question de l'application des accords de
minsk seuls textes signés et reconnu par
l'ukraine et la russie alors que cela
fait maintenant sept ans que ce conflit
a commencé et rien n'incite à
l'optimisme kiev a adopté des sanctions
contre des entreprises russes sanction
qui devrait engendrer des mesures
réciproques de la part de moscou et
aucune réunion internationale au format
normandie par exemple n'est prévue pour
le moment
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre laurent un journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de l'ex urss bonsoir ça va
merci d'être avec nous le chef de la
diplomatie européenne qui assure donc
kiev de son soutien indéfectible
en tout cas celui de bruxelles quelle
est la portée de cette déclaration pour
le moment ce sont des mots depuis
longtemps depuis le début du conflit
bruxelles soutient kiev même si il y à
une médiation française et allemande qui
oblige la france l'allemagne a éteint un
peu moins favorable à kiev et essayer de
d'être impartial ces derniers temps ce
n'est plus réellement le cas
actuellement on est dans une phase très
très particulière c'est en quelque sorte
une prophétie auto réalisatrice
vous savez lorsque on pense qu'un que
l'adversaire va faire un mouvement ont
fait soi-même un mouvement et la dette
c'est reparti avec soin ce mouvement
comme une menace et avance lui même est
finalement alors qu'il n'y avait aucune
raison que les choses s'enveniment et
bien elle s'envenime naturellement et on
est au début de ce mouvement est ce
qu'il va s'arrêter
vraisemblablement parce que personne n'a
intérêt à aller plus loin dans le
conflit
ça veut dire quoi concrètement on sait
que les relations entre la russie et
l'europe sont déjà très tendu vous venez
de le dire personne n'a intérêt à aller
plus loin dans le conflit mais ça risque
d'empirer à la lumière des derniers
événements
il ya toujours une possibilité de
dérapage lorsque je dis que personne n'a
intérêt à aller plus loin dans le
conflit c'est dans ce conflit là c'est à
dire le conflit du donbass avec des
dizaines des centaines de morts
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit je crois que
actuellement la situation est très
claire
d'un côté il y a les républiques
autoproclamées qui sont sur l'or sur le
territoire qu'elle revendique elle ne
revendique pas autre chose
elle ne revendique pas d'aller plus loin
en revanche l'ukraine depuis 2014 veut
récupérer ses territoires
eux ils ont tout intérêt à aller plus
loin à grignoter des territoires
actuellement par la négociation rien
n'est possible parce que l'un des
accords l'un des principes de minsk qui
était l'un des points essentiels pour
les républiques autoproclamées c'était
l'autonomie inscrite dans la
constitution et ce à kiev depuis
maintenant six ans s'ils refusent les
accords de minsk 2 ont été signés en
février 2015 fesses ça fait maintenant
plus de six ans que ils ne sont pas
appliqués à cause de ça effectivement
moscou accusé l'ukraine de ne pas
respecter ces accords de minsk
clairement ils sont en danger ils ont
ils sont un danger ces accords de minsk
pour une conception de l'ukraine qui et
l'ukraine état unitaire à l'image de la
france c'est à dire en france pendant un
siècle entier le jacobinisme pas imposer
aux moyens parfois de massacres comme en
vendée mais plus tard par des politiques
très rigoureuse que les particularismes
régionaux disparaissent et on a créé par
la violence par la contrainte un état
unitaire
aujourd'hui c'est formidable nous sommes
tous français que l'on soit alsacien
breton ou provençal nous sommes tous
français en ukraine ce n'est pas le cas
depuis trente ans on essaye de créer un
état unitaire alors que les
particularismes sont très très virulents
entre est très marqué dans dans la
population ukrainienne
il y à des citoyens ukrainiens qui avait
jadis la nationalité russe ou grecs ou
peu importe
et qui aujourd'hui ont perdu leur
nationalité ils ne sont plus considérés
que comme ukrainien c'est un peu comme
si ils avaient été dépouillés de leur
identité et ses identités là aussi bien
dans le dos basque dans d'autres régions
comme la france quatre ans karpaty les
les gens aimeraient bien pouvoir s'auto
gérer d'une certaine manière il ne
demande pas à sortir d'ukraine il
demande simplement que les la
constitution ukrainienne leur donne le
droit de
de parler leur langue de s'entendre dans
leur langue et d'avoir leurs
particularismes régionaux
c'est tout ce qu'ils demandent ce que
vous venez de nous décrire très bien
pierre laurin c'est un aspect de la
question qui n'est pas de considérer
qu'il n'ait pas vu par justement
l'europe
non l'europe ne voit pas cela parce que
elle considère que l'état ukrainien doit
être unitaire et il n'y a pas de raison
qu'il y ait des particularismes d
autonomie il n'y a pas de raisons pour
les européens de voir leur propre
exemple si vous avez l'allemagne est un
état fédéral
mais avec une langue unique donc c'est
un peu particulier mais la grande
bretagne c'est un état c'était avant de
ces elle l'est toujours mais elle ne
fait plus partie de l'union européenne
mais c'est un état également avec dédé d
autonomie très forte pour les
différentes régions qui se considèrent
comme des états et nous mêmes nous les
considérons comme des états puisque nous
organisons ddd match de rugby avec des
des participants qui pour la plupart
sont des des britanniques mais on
considère que le pays de galles et anita
etc
en espagne les autonomies ont une large
liberté même si le roman même si
certaines demandes plus comme la
catalogne et pourquoi refuserait ton
incertaine région ukrainienne ce que
l'on considère comme normale dans
d'autres pays que je viens de citer
alors qui a dit que la russie veut
tester joe biden
voilà et en russie on estime plutôt que
l'ukraine seraient prêtes à attaquer se
sentant soutenus par washington qui dit
vrai je crois que pendant tout le tout
le mandat les cinq ans ou petro
porochenko était président il
n'attendait que le feu vert de
washington pour lancer une attaque parce
qu'il croyait que les forces de l'otan
le soutiendrai évidemment lorsque donald
trump est arrivé au pouvoir
washington ccc espoir n'était plus aussi
l'actualité ce qu'il convient également
de voir c'est que l'otan organise en
ukraine des déformations pour l'armée
ukrainienne qu'il y à des manoeuvres qui
sont prévus dans un proche avenir que
l'otan en elle-même organise
régulièrement des manoeuvres tout le
long de la frontière russe en mer noire
des bateaux de l'otan mènent également
des manoeuvres régulièrement et là on
voudrait interdire à la russie de faire
des mouvements de troupe à l'intérieur
de son territoire
je rappelle que les deux forces
américaines qui sont en europe dans le
cadre de l'otan sont à 6000 km de leur
base
et on voudrait interdire aux forces
russes d'organiser des manoeuvres ou des
déplacements de troupes à l'intérieur de
leurs propres frontières
ça c'est un peu un peu curieux c'est à
dire c'est une conception 2d du droit
international qui est très particulier
donc nous nous avons le droit en tant
qu'occidentaux de faire ce que nous
voulons nous voulons mais en revanche la
russie elle n'a pas le droit de faire ce
qu'elle veut à l'intérieur de ses
propres frontières
merci pierre laurin d'avoir été avec
nous avoir apporté votre analyse
de nouvelles tensions entre la grèce et
la turquie au sujet de l'immigration ce
week-end athènes a une fois de plus
accusé ankara de provocation elle lui
reproche d'encourager les migrants
accoster sur les côtes grecques côtes
grecs accusations qui intervient à la
fin à la veille d'une rencontre entre
bruxelles et ankara
et alors que lieu se dit prête à renouer
le dialogue avec la turquie après après
des mois de troubles en méditerranée
orientale
quand un mot clair après un entretien
par visioconférence le 19 mars dernier
les discussions se poursuivront ce mardi
entre la turquie et l'union européenne
notamment sur la question migratoire
bruxelles met en avant un agenda plus
positif entre les deux parties mais
reste néanmoins mesuré face à la main
tendue par est celle tayyip erdogan
depuis le début de l'année nous allons
collaborer davantage avec la turquie
champ des questions telles que la
migration le financement les dialogues
de haut niveau et la modernisation de
l'union douanière
si la turquie n'avance pas de manière
constructive si elle revient à des
actions unilatérales ou des provocations
en particulier en méditerranée orientale
nous prendrons bien entendu ces mesures
de coopération dans un climat
d'apaisement après une année 2001
marquée par une escalade des tensions
entre les deux parties
outre les dissensions sur les dossiers
syrien et libyen ainsi que la
dégradation des relations avec la france
les fortes tensions en méditerranée
orientale ont cristallisé les positions
au deuxième semestre de l'année dernière
en cause plusieurs missions de forage
sur des sites d'exploitation gazière
situés dans des eaux grecs et chypriotes
début mars le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan a réagi face aux
accusations de conquête territoriale en
méditerranée orientale
comme nous l'avons toujours dit nous ne
convoite ont pas la terre la mer ou la
souveraineté dans notre pays
nous essayons seulement de protéger
notre patrie et nos droits
autre sujet de tension la question
migratoire l'union européenne et
notamment la grèce s'écharpent
régulièrement avec la turquie sur la
gestion de l'arrivée des migrants et
réfugiés vendredi dernier athènes a
accusé les garde-côtes turcs d'avoir
voulu provoquer une escalade en mer egée
en passant très rapidement devant un
navire grec
les gardes-côtes hellénique on signalait
de multiples incidents au cours desquels
les garde-côtes et la marine turques ont
accompagné de frêles bateaux de migrants
jusqu'à la frontière maritime de
l'europe dont le but de provoquer une
escalade avec la grèce il ne fait aucun
doute que ces migrants ont quitté les
côtes turquie et puisqu'il était
soutenue par la turquie
il ne courait aucun risque nous appelons
la turquie à se retirer de ces eaux a
raccompagné ses migrants en toute
sécurité en turquie et à se montrer à la
hauteur de la déclaration conjointe de
2016 sur les migrations la problématique
migratoire n'est pas récente
la grèce a de nombreuses fois accusé
ankara de laisser les exilés franchir
ses frontières
mais l'accord ue turquie de 2016 a fait
chuter drastiquement le nombre de
migrants en entrant dans l'union
européenne
le renouvellement de cette coopération
sera d'ailleurs au coeur des discussions
à ankara ce mardi on pour en parler nous
sommes avec un conte blanche maison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir quant aux raisons merci d'être
avec nous l'europe
ankara demain comment va-t-elle être
reçus je crois qu'elle va très bien su
parce que d'abord monsieur erdogan a
changé ton depuis le début de l'année il
ne fait plus discours incendiaire voire
injurieux comme il le faisait auparavant
et puis les plus protégés par le
président des états unis pense que
monsieur maiden aride attitude
différente que celle de son de son
prédécesseur il est aussi réaliste
l'union européenne reste le premier
partenaire économique de la turquie
elle est d'ailleurs en union douanière
avec l'union européenne 7e turquie et
par conséquent monsieur erdogan à
redoute tout à fait d'éventuelles
sanctions qui serait très dommageable
pour l'économie turque
alors madame ursula von der leyen et
monsieur charles michel font le voyage
ils font l'effort en pleine pandémie de
se rendre à ankara et je crois que le
président erdogan apprécié cette
démarche et que d'ailleurs à lui donne
l'occasion de montrer une certaine
autonomie de manoeuvre par rapport à
d'autres grands partenaires comme les
etats-unis la russie la chine l'iran ou
les pays arabes et il montre qu'il n'est
pas isolé
donc il a un intérêt important dans
cette affaire d'autant plus qu'il peut
évoquer avec les représentants de
l'union européenne l'émigration mais
aussi beaucoup d'autres sujets l'union
douanière les visas et beaucoup d'autres
sujets ils évoqueront probablement
demain alors évidemment demain les
sujets ça sera la question migratoire en
premier lieu que va demander président
turc
le président turc va d'abord demandé
l'application complète de l'accord de
mars 2016 qui a donc cinq ans exactement
au tir haute aux termes de cet accord
l'union européenne promettait à la
turquie 6 milliards d'euros ce qui est
considérable versée en deux tranches et
ses 6 milliards devaient servir par
l'intermédiaire d'un certain nombre
d'organismes qui n'était pas le
gouvernement turc notamment le croissant
rouge en liaison avec la croix rouge
internationale pour aider par conséquent
les enfants des migrants à aller à
l'école et pour aider l'ensemble de ces
migrants a allait avoir des soins
ces migrants sont très nombreux puisque
il y actuellement en turquie 3 millions
600 mille syrien plus environ
quatre cent cinquante mille migrants
venant d'afghanistan ou d'ailleurs
mais je crois qu'il faut remarquer et on
ne dit pas encore suffisamment que un
grand nombre de ces migrants se sont
intégrés dans la société turque est à
dire qu ils ne sont plus dans les camps
où il était à la frontière syrienne
ils sont dans les villes turques et la
plupart d'entre eux ont cherché un
emploi où on l'on trouvait souvent dans
le secteur informel
donc c'est très difficile de dire
exactement quel pourcentage mais se sont
installés et dans le fond très peu
d'entre eux ont l'intention de venir en
europe n'avait pas la même chose pour
les migrants afghans et pour ceux qui ne
venaient pas de syrie donc c'est la
première chose il va probablement dire
que cet accord n'a pas été totalement
respecté mais reste des sommes à verser
tout simplement parce que l'union
européenne raisonne en termes de crédits
d'engagement et madame fatara yen va
répéter demain que tous les engagements
ont été faits à hauteur de 6 milliards
d'euros
mais évidemment les crédits de paiement
qui sont ceux qui intéressent la turquie
son compte à un certain retard sur
l'engagement il faut conclure des
contrats avec des opérateurs et cela
peut prendre un certain temps
quelquefois plusieurs mois quelquefois
un an ou ou 18 mois et c'est ce retard
qui fait qu' il ya une disparité entre
les statistiques bruxellois lé fait
bruxelloise et l'impression de la
turquie alors monsieur erdogan va
répondre à madame van der leyen s'est
lui dit que après tout tous les fronts
été versée il veut dire on va et c'est
très bien
et maintenant il faut sans doute
prolonger cet accord c'est-à-dire
conclure un deuxième accord pour
financer l'intégration des syriens et de
tous ces immigrants dans l'économie
turque qui a été tout à fait
un parti qui m'ont mise à plat par la
pandémie de lakovic 19
elle était déjà en mauvais état
auparavant et la crise économique c'est
évidemment aggravé donc il va
probablement demander une aide
financière additionnelle
il va aussi demander d'autres choses
bien sûr il va demander de perfectionner
l'union douanière peut être même de
reprendre la négociation d'adhésion à
l'issue de cette rencontre club
blanchemaison peut-il y avoir selon vous
un rapprochement entre l'union
européenne et la turquie
peut-être mais ça va être difficile
compte tenu de l'attitude qu'a eue
monsieur erdogan au cours de la période
récente en fin d'année dernière
notamment compte tenu des mots qu'il a
employés contre certains chefs d'états
d'états membres de l'union européenne et
il est probable que s'il demande une
reprise de la négociation d'adhésion
c'est une négociation qui a été ouverte
il ya 20 ans on chapitre sur 36 ont été
ouverts bien sûr on pourrait toujours
faire semblant et dire qu'on ouvre le
12e pour lui faire plaisir mais je pense
que même là dessus un certain nombre
d'états membres diront non s'agissant de
l'union douanière il va demander un
perfectionnement cette union douanière
une amélioration de la fluidité des
échanges entre la turquie et l'union
européenne
et là aussi il est bien possible que
ayez des réticences de la part de
certains états membres
1 selon que le volet financier est à
dire la négociation d'un nouvel accord
qui probablement d'ailleurs serait moins
important par son volume que la corde il
ya cinq ans puisque un certain nombre de
réfugiés s'intègre dans la société dans
la société turque et que finalement ils
jouent leur rôle c'était des syriens
assez souvent diplômés et qu'ils ont
trouvé leur place dans l'économie turque
alors par ailleurs évidemment d'autres
sujets peuvent être évoqués les
négociations avec la grèce qui vont sans
doute durer encore longtemps parce que
le sujet de la v10 délimitation des
plateaux continentaux et est extrêmement
difficile et peut-être d'autres sujets
comme
le retrait des mercenaires syrien que la
turquie avait envoyé en libye
il ne semble pas être totalement
effectué et puis peut-être d'autres
sujets qui seront soulevées d'un côté ou
de l'autre
alors ça veut dire que le dialogue sera
renouer et c'est une bonne chose ça veut
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de difficultés à
surmonter mais que peut-être que la
menace que leur disais aussi plané au
dessus de la tête de l'union européenne
à savoir que monsieur erdogan ouvre les
camps et lâche des milliers des
centaines de milliers de réfugiés
cette menace n'est peut-être pas aussi
réel qu'on le dit puisque encore une
fois il n'y a plus de camps et un
certain nombre de réfugiés sont dans les
villes turques inséré dans l'économie
dans l'économie turque
merci claude blanchemaison rester avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la vaccination la france
qui appuient sur l'accélérateur le stade
de france transformée en vaccinodromes
dès demain et lancement cette semaine de
la production de vaccins sur le sol
français mais nous verrons que tout
n'est pas aussi simple
et puis nous parlerons de l'europe la
grèce et le portugal qui se dé confirme
peuple et qui rompt volet commerce alors
que le royaume uni
il va tester un système de passeport
sanitaire des familles avril
[Musique]
oh
comment vous jugez vous la situation
aujourd'hui après plus d'un an de crise
le tourisme est probablement l'une des
filières qui souffrent le plus de la
crise sanitaire le tourisme et
l'événementiel c'est à dire en fait tout
ce qui crée des flux de population tout
ce qui crée des rassemblements comment
vous voyez là les possibilités de faire
redémarrer tout ça le rôle des élus en
ce moment qu'ils soient nationaux ou
locaux
c'est de trouver le juste équilibre
entre la protection sanitaire et donc la
disparition du virus interne et la vie
économique et la vie sociale
on voit bien que y'a pas clavier
économique qui est touché il ya toute la
psychologie des gens c'est trop long
donc il faut ajuster les protocoles
sanitaires à une vie économique
culturelle sportive événementielle qui
puisse renaître
je
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre les politiques et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde vivre
avec la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
les trente ans que les cours sont
manipulés comment est-ce qu'on peut
réguler ça on ne peut pas c'est une
manipulation on va dire 2-0 civilité de
cette manipulation est encore plus
facile parce que vous avez de nouveaux
traders parce que vous avez des gens qui
ont été attirés par l'argent assez
facile le bitcoin illustre quelque chose
qui existe de toute éternité gagner de
l'argent en ne faisant rien en achetant
un actif qui nous vaut intrinsèquement
rien grâce à des gogos qui n'y
comprennent rien sauf la promesse de
faire fortune qui en profitent
réellement de ces manipulations pour
malheureusement c'est pas les petites
sardines c'est des requins le petit
particulier il est là pour se faire
prendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adepte de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
et grands
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 5 avril
la campagne de vaccination en france des
hôpitaux militaires prêts à accueillir
les volontaires à l'injection antico
vide le stade de france transformée en
vaccinodromes et le lancement cette
semaine de la production des qs sur le
sol français sauf qu'un centre de
vaccination a dû fermer plus tôt ce
week-end a calé faute de volontaires
pour se faire vacciner elle astrazeneca
et alors que la france construit sa
première semaine de confinement musée
collège et terrasses de café rouvre au
portugal 2e étape d'un plan de
déconfinement progressif réouverture
également en grèce malgré des chiffres
toujours inquiétant le gouvernement
espère lancer un peu plus l'économie qui
souffre fortement de la réduction du
tourisme préserver les enfants des rêves
tout au moins de celui de voler en
france la maire écologiste de
poitiers a jeté un pavé dans la mare
après que le conseil municipal de la
ville a voté une baisse de subvention à
2,0 bauer de poitiers et n'a pas manqué
de faire réagir la classe politique
une mesure utile ou une énième polémique
autour d'un maire et europe ecologie les
verts ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
une affirmation hypocrite une chasse aux
sorcières benyamin nétanyahou se défend
après les attaques de la procureure lors
de la reprise de son procès pour
corruption dans la matinée elles
l'accusent d'avoir usé de son pouvoir de
façon illégitime au bénéfice de ses
affaires personnelles
les consultations post élection
déterminante pour l'avenir politique du
chef du likoud ont ainsi débuté
[Musique]
la france va produire massivement des
vaccins dès cette semaine annonce
dimanche de thierry breton le
commissaire européen en charge de la
task force vexin alors que le pays
connaît toujours des difficultés
d'approvisionnement
alors la fabrication au made in france
pourra-t-elle changer la donne éléments
de réponse avec solène godin 5 sites
fabriquons les vaccins en france
les sérums deux trois voire quatre
laboratoires seront produits sur le
territoire national des usines sous
traitantes destinées seulement aux
flaconnage à l'emballage et à
l'aseptisation les substances chimiques
quand elles seront toujours produite
exclusivement par les sites étrangers
détenteurs des brevets problème les
usines françaises seront donc dépendante
de la capacité de production et de la
logistique de leurs partenaires
étrangers est une fabrication plusieurs
étapes
pas si simple à coordonner pour le
vaccin de pfizer par exemple le produit
contenant la rn messager est élaboré à
mayence en allemagne
la formulation c'est à dire l'âge où
d'autres substances se déroule en
belgique
enfin la mise en flacon se fera en
partie en france en tout dans l'union
européenne
53 sites devraient fabriquer des vaccins
mais cette production dans l'hexagone ne
signifie pas que les français pourront
en profiter directement en effet selon
thierry breton 60% des doses produites
seront destinés aux états membres
c'est l'union européenne qui décidera du
nombre de doses attribué à chaque pays
les 40% restants seront exportés hors
union européenne
une collaboration qui se veut gage
d'efficacité européenne dans la
production de vaccins mais qui se heurte
déjà à des critiques quant au manque
d'autonomie
finalement c'est sanofi qui devrait d
ailleurs à mettre ces vaccins en flacons
ou et la souveraineté
le lancement de cette production
française revêt aussi un intérêt
politique montrer la capacité des usines
françaises à produire rapidement au
moment où le gouvernement et les
laboratoires sont pointés du doigt pour
la faiblesse de l'industrie nationale
toute la
stratégie collective du pays depuis 20
25 ans a été de créer les conditions qui
ont amené des choix de délocalisation de
prélèvements obligatoires trop élevé
c'est le choix de sacrifier son appareil
industriel et aujourd'hui on le paie
cher
une fabrication nationale qui s'annonce
d'ores et déjà comme un pari périlleux
pour la france et pour parler de cette
stratégie nous sommes avec vincent jean
brun maire de l'haÿ les roses dans le
val de marne président du groupe libre
républicaine rien dépendant pour le
conseil régional d'île de france
bonsoir vincent genvrin merci à d'être
avec nous alors il ya quelques semaines
on s'en souvient vous nous racontiez vos
déboires comment vous alliez chercher
vaillamment les doses de vaccins avec
votre petite voiture est ce que ça s'est
amélioré au monde de ce point de vue là
écoutez c'est toujours aussi compliqué
pour nous de faire avancer cette
stratégie vaccinale
on se réjouissait il ya quelques jours
en entendant qu'on allait à produire des
vaccins sur notre sol et puis votre
reportage le montre bien quelle
désillusion ce qu'on se rend compte que
on va en réalité simplement en mettre en
bouteille des flacons donc en réalité on
participe certes un petit peu à l'effort
de guerre européen mais b sans plus
et puis surtout on est toujours toujours
en train de ramer à contre-courant et je
crois que c'est ce qui est le plus usant
pour toutes celles et ceux qui sont
mobilisées pour faire réussir cette
stratégie vaccinale notamment parce
qu'on voit bien il ya une lourdeur
administrative et une peau cratie qui
nous empêchent d'avancer et ça devient
vraiment insupportable clairement
vincent jean bras concrètement sur le
terrain sur votre terrain qu'est ce que
vous rencontrez le plus au genre de
bitam difficulté d'abord on a toujours
ce problème d'approvisionnement des
doses
il faut quand même qu'on en ait
conscience vous avez dans les titres
parler des supers vaccinodromes qui
allait ouvrir donc là aussi quand
l'annoncé faite tout le monde s'en
réjouit et se dire génial et on peut y
avoir une vraie avancée dans la
vaccination
et puis une rumeur se fait jour à savoir
que pour alimenter les vaccinodromes et
bien il en prendrait des doses au centre
de vaccination déjà existants le
gouvernement le démon du normand pas du
tout vous inquiétez pas et puis la
réalité est là maintenant à un grand
nombre de
l'aig voit les doses de primo injection
diminué et je discutais encore tout à
l'heure avec des collègues dans les
hauts de seine
eux ils passent carrément à 0 dose de
vaccination pour les primo injection
toute la semaine prochaine pourquoi
parce qu'en fait ça permet d'alimenter
les fêtes communication que sont ces le
méga giga vaccine vraiment notre premier
problème concret c'est celui là c'est le
fait qu'ils manquent toujours des doses
et que le gouvernement nous donne
l'impression de jouer à tour de
passe-passe pour les passants demain
vaccinodromes un super vaccinodromes
mais dans la pratique il manque toujours
des doses c'est ensuite l'autre sujet
important et l'autre sujet important
c'est que je disais sur la bureaucratie
c'est que il ya eu un vrai scandale
d'état d'abord c'est celui des seringue
vous avez comme tout le monde suivi
cette affaire cinq doses en un flacon
puis 6
et puis maintenant sans qu on arrive
quasiment tout le temps en fait recette
et qu'est ce qui a changé simplement les
seringue et avec les super seringue
d'aujourd'hui on arrive à faire cette
dose mais elles n'ont pas été inventés
entre-temps les seringue elle existait
depuis le départ c'est un modèle
particulier qu'on aurait pu commander
par anticipation depuis longtemps donc
il ya un véritable scandale d'état parce
qu'en réalité on a jeté cette sixième et
7/7 dose pendant beaucoup trop longtemps
et tout simplement ce que le
gouvernement n'ait pas anticipé la
commande des bonnes seringue
ça c'est un vrai vrai vrai sujet pour
nous et je rajoute à ça toutes les
lourdeurs administratives auxquelles on
fait face avec des doses qui peuvent
être jetés enfin je reconnais tout
simplement parce que la rs agence
régionale de santé nous interdit de les
transférer d'un centre de vaccination à
un autre parce que ça rentre pas dans
leur petit tableau mais dans la pratique
on pourrait sauver des doses comme ça et
quand on leur dit mais attendez j'ai
cinq doses sur les bras
il suffit de les transférer au centre
d'à côté qui a cinq patients qui
attendent
on nous dit 90 ça rentre pas dans nos
chiffres vaut mieux les jeter vincent ça
me paraît incroyable effectivement on a
tous autour de nous et nous les premiers
d'ailleurs on a peut-être envie de se
faire vacciner comment peut-on expliquer
qu'on jette des doses parce que vous
n'êtes pas le premier à le dire on
l'entend ici ou là ça veut dire quoi que
chaque sens tu n'as pas de listes
d'attentes qu'on peut appeler au dernier
moment
c'est aussi au niveau régional et là je
vous taquine un peu mais mais c'est pas
mieux organiser même au sens voilà des
mairies des régions etc
en fait on fait le maximum en permanence
comme on a on n'a pas le nombre de
vaccins al avance d'une semaine sur
l'autre ça s'est amélioré un petit peu
ces derniers temps mais il y avait
vraiment ce problème ou démarrage de la
vaccination ou en fait on nous annonçait
en quasiment le matin le nombre 12 qu'on
aurait pour la semaine après vous avez
un effet particulier c'est c'est celui
que j'ai évoqués sur la 7ème dose comme
cette septième dose n'est pas
officiellement reconnue
ça signifie que dans la journée on va
pouvoir tirer sur la seringue parfois
7/7 doses quand on a cette septième dos
ça veut dire qu'on a la peau toute la
possibilité de vacciner un peu plus que
ce qui était prévu à l'origine
et c'est là où en fait on va se
retrouver avec un des doses en
surnuméraire et pas forcément les
rendez-vous qui ont été calés pour ça
est également tout simplement assis sur
planning et des médecins des infirmiers
en amont arrive un petit peu en fin de
journée et c'est là on se dit ben attia
le centre d'à côté qui a une qui ouvrait
une demi heure de plus peut être que ils
auront la possibilité de le faire
ou encore ça c'est tout un tas de
petites exemple très concret on se dit
on nous fait pas assez confiance parce
que la bureaucratie est fait de telle
manière qu un centre à un droit à
vacciner d'un nombre près fixé c'est à
dire que dans mon centre se donne un
chiffre qui a savary un petit peu de
jour en jour mais si on a le droit de
faire 75 primo injection par jour
eh ben vous n'avez pas le droit de faire
la 76e injection et il est plutôt
qu'être souple sur ce type de choses on
va nous dire en fin de journée le mans
va ce qu'il vous reste une ou deux rames
tant pis ce que vous avez un soignant
chez vous soit tant pis je t'ai là
plutôt que la donner à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est vraiment rageant on se croit dans
les douze travaux d'astérix ou en fait
on est en permanence une administration
qui vient nous met des bâtons dans les
roues là où elle devrait en fait vous
faciliter la vie
on entend bien le problème alors il ya
aussi par exemple illustration à calais
un centre qui a dû fermer plus tôt ce
week-end parce que il y avait des
vaccins qui n'ont pas trouvé preneurs
ces vaccins sont spécifiques ce sont les
astrazeneca parce qu'il ya de la défense
qu'est ce que ça vous
pires que vous connaissez ce problème
chez vous aussi à l'haÿ les roses oui
dans ce centre de vaccination chez nous
on a du fader comme la liste d'attenté
très longues
quand le gouvernement a annoncé la
possibilité de se faire vacciner avec
astrazeneca un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens qui était en droit vu leur
âge d'avoir du finder on dit ah super je
vais aller me faire vacciner chez mon
médecin avec d'astrazeneca et puis
ensuite il ya eu toutes les affaires
qu'on connaît le gouvernement qui avait
quand même suspendu pendant plusieurs
jours ce vaccin et on a vu les patients
qui avaient qui s'était quasiment
désinscrit de la liste d'attentes
revenir vers le centre de vaccination en
disant qu'à un jeu du finder
j'ai pas confiance alors évidemment moi
je suis pas médecin
comme tout le monde je me dis bon il
faut qu'on fasse confiance à un moment
donné aux sachants on voit les pistes
artistiques en grande bretagne ou la
grande bretagne ont été vaccinées
qu'avec de l'astra zeneca globalement ça
s'est très bien passé donc j'aurai envie
spontanément de rassurer mes concitoyens
mais d'un autre côté la vérité c'est que
le gouvernement n'a rien fait pour nous
rassurer et je peux comprendre
l'inquiétude même si elle n'est pas
basée sur des faits scientifiques mais
en tout cas il soit qu'elles soient
réelles c'est de se dire si gouvernement
lui-même n'a pas eu confiance dans un
vaccin au point de le suspendre
bon oui un doute il ya un vrai doute et
on a un vrai problème avec ce vaccin et
si on veut mais si on veut leur donner
cette confiance il faut que le
gouvernement montre l'exemple beaucoup
plus qu'il ne l'a fait juste ici alors
montré l'exemple ça nous ramène cette
affaire de restaurants clandestins on
rappelle qu'une enquête est en cours
quel est votre tour de vous dans votre
administration la réaction justement des
administrés par rapport à ce genre
d'affaires la plupart des de ce qu'ils
ont pu en discuter ils sont choqués
objectivement parce que ya cette idée
que tout le monde fait des efforts et
que on risque d'avoir cette pandémie qui
dure par l'inconstance est là la
rébellion de certains donc c'est assez
rageant
et j'ai aussi discuté avec des
restaurateurs qui par définition sont
soit fermées soit uniquement en
livraison et qui enrageait en fait en
dix ans mais nous on respecte les règles
du jeu
on s'adapte comme on peut et il ya des
collègues qui jouent pas le jeu c'est
scandaleux
surtout qu'en plus il y avait dans ce
reportage paix restons quand même très
haut de gamme enfin dans l'esprit donc
il y avait un côté en plus l'élite qui
ce qui se fait plaisir et donc il ya une
vraie colère de ceux qui ont ouvert ce
contre ceux qui ont ouvert ces
restaurants clandestins mais aussi ceux
qui se sont permis de les fréquenter
parce que c'est c'est c'est honteux
quand on pense à l'intérêt général
or on le disait aussi lors des débats à
20 heures il ya aussi le simple brise
trop peut-être plus simple qui qui ouvre
de manière clandestine ça pose aussi la
question de fond de l'acceptabilité de
de ce troisième confinement même si le
gouvernement veut pas qu'on utilise ce
mot vous vous administrez comment ça se
passe et ce qui est des décisions est ce
qu'il ya un respect des des restrictions
de de bon coeur on sent que là c'est
celle de trop non il ya effectivement
beaucoup de problèmes posés vis-à-vis de
la fermeture des écoles parce que la
suisse est une vraie tension non pas sur
le fait de les fermer mais sur le fait
de les fermer du jour au lendemain alors
qu'on savait que la situation serait
celle ci que des politiques comme
valérie pécresse avait proposé des
semaines et des semaines avant de ce2
d'avancer les vacances scolaires donc on
aurait pu anticiper ça c'est vraiment le
point de crispation fort pour le reste
objectivement j'ai cette chance d'être
dans une commune où globalement les
règles sont encore bien respectées elles
le sont d'autant plus que ce confinement
qui n'en est pas vraiment avec la
possibilité de sortir et s'aérer fait
que globalement ça se passe à peu près
bien c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
quand on se promène dans paris pour y
circuler de temps en temps on voit que
là dessus
le peintre dans la capitale le port du
masque n'est pas très bien respectée que
j'ai pu apercevoir beaucoup
d'attroupement on sent que dans
certaines zones où notamment les espaces
verts des espaces de respiration en
moins présent la tension grandit et je
crois que les dernières promesses du
gouvernement et notamment d' emmanuel
macron ont intérêt à être tenues parce
que sinon on va arriver à saturation et
on peut vaincre à un craquage
merci beaucoup en tout cas vincent
genvrin d'avoir été avec nous au maire
de l'haÿ les roses dans le vin
de marne merci à vous et c'est une
partie de l'europe est confiné certains
pays lève les restrictions c'est le cas
par exemple de la grèce ou du portugal
qui commencent ou accélère aujourd'hui
leurs plans de déconfinement objectif
pour ces états à lever les contraintes
au plus vite afin d'attirer notamment
les touristes pour la période estivale
qui approche
athènes et lisbonne qui voit d'un bon
oeil la possible mise en place d'un
passeport sanitaire au royaume uni plus
de précision avec thé au combat après
plusieurs mois dans un brouillard de
restrictions le portugal pourrait enfin
entre apercevoir la lumière musée
collège et terrasses rouvre ce lundi
après plus de deux mois de fermeture un
plan de déconfinement commencé le 15
mars dernier avec la réouverture des
écoles primaires une levée des
restrictions permise par une
amélioration de la situation sanitaire
dans le pays ce qui n'est pas le cas de
la grèce qui voit le nombre de nouveaux
cas de comics 19 augmenté pourtant le
gouvernement a autorisé les magasins à
rouvrir pour le plus grand bonheur de
ses habitants
heureusement le marché a rouvert et nous
pouvons voir le retour des passants
j'espère que les mesures sanitaires
seront maintenus et que les personnes
responsables quart de rond leurs
distances et feront leur courses afin
que le gouvernement ne nous ferme pas à
nouveau
nous sommes heureux d'être ouverts
aujourd'hui nous pensons que le public
répondra présent et qu'il viendra nous
avons déjà plusieurs appels et quelques
commandes
nous espérons que cela ne soit que le
début
en difficulté économique en raison de la
faible activité touristique athènes
accélère sa stratégie de déconfinement
objectif accueillir des touristes dès le
mois de mai prochain
pour cela le gouvernement de kyriakos
mitsotakis comme ses homologues
portugais compte beaucoup sur la mise en
place d'un passeport sanitaire tous deux
voient d'un bon oeil les annonces de
londres boris johnson ayant annoncé
aujourd'hui le lancement d'un test de ce
dispositif prochainement ce qui est
certainement vrai c'est que l'idée d'un
certificat de vaccination sera
certainement utile pour les voyages
internationaux
c'est quelque chose sur quoi tous les
pays travaillent et je pense que les
touristes devront faire avec et nous
devons y penser
très avancé dans sa campagne de
vaccination avec plus de 30 millions de
personnes immunisées
l'ex maire de londres se sait attendu
sur ce sujet polémique
chaque été des dizaines de milliers de
touristes britanniques se rendent dans
le sud de l'europe pour y profiter de
leurs vacances
une manne vitale pour la grèce comme
pour le portugal en irlande du nord les
violences se poursuivent dimanche soir
de nouveaux affrontements ont opposé les
policiers aux manifestants unionistes
ces derniers protestent contre les
mesures imposées dans le cadre de
l'accord sur le break site contexte qui
fait revivre les craintes de nouveaux
heurts avec les partisans d'une
réunification de l'irlande
le gouvernement britannique lance un
appel au calme
françois xavier lambert les véhicules de
la police nord-irlandaise se déploie
dimanche soir pour disperser les
manifestants de la mouvance unionistes
le camp politique qui soutient le
maintien de la province au sein du
royaume uni selon les forces de l'ordre
une vingtaine de personnes ont mené une
attaque orchestrée
je tends notamment des cocktails molotov
contre les policiers
le gouvernement britannique a condamné
ces violences
il n'y a aucune excuse pour la violence
pas maintenant jamais ceux qui se
livrent à la violence et à la
criminalité n'ont rien à offrir leurs
actions ne sont pas voulu et ne sauront
jamais toléré je remercie tous ces
policiers qui continue de travailler dur
pour protéger les gens du danger
ces incidents sont directement liés à la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord sur le break
sitz et à ses conséquences pour
l'irlande du nord
les unionistes rejette le protocole
négocié entre londres et l'union
européenne un accord qui introduit des
contrôles sur les marchandises arrivant
en irlande du nord depuis la
grande-bretagne double objectif pour
bruxelles éviter le retour d'une
frontières douanières avec la république
d'irlande et préserver le marché unique
européen
selon lui le retour d'une barrière
douanière entre les deux irlande
risquerait de fragiliser la paix conclu
en 1998 entre les principales forces
politiques d'irlande du nord
une paix qui mettait fin à 30 ans de
guerre entre unionistes et républicains
irlandais dans ce contexte londres a
unilatéralement repoussé au 1er octobre
prochain la mise en place de ce
protocole afin de laisser du temps aux
entreprises
nous prenons des mesures légales et
techniques pour construire la confiance
c'est la bonne chose à faire vu l'impact
sur l'accord de paix du vendredi saint
et le besoin d'avoir le consentement des
deux communautés
mais l'initiative britannique n'est pas
du goût de la commission européenne qui
accuse londres d'avoir violé les règles
douanières convenu pour l'irlande du
nord
bruxelles a annoncé l'ouverture de deux
procédures contre le royaume uni
les retours en france avec cette alerte
à la pollution en haute savoie un
collectif dénonce la mauvaise qualité de
l'air qui affecte selon eux la santé des
habitants de la ville de la vallée de
l'arve en cause les émanations toxiques
des entreprises reportage le cas tu as
avec estelle farges
bon alors moi je vais là on va lui faire
une grande bouteille d'oxygène ont une
petite allée bouteilles d'oxygène
déchets toxiques chez aurélie et son
fils ethan dix ans le champ lexical de
la pollution sept invités jusque dans
les loisirs
on va dire que celui là est large pire
est beaucoup trop de personnes parlent
pas bien mary fils vivent ta pas si dans
la vallée de l'arve
malgré le cadre idyllique la pollution
environnante a peu à peu transformé leur
quotidien à commencer par celui des
tannes petit la fin beaucoup
bronchiolite il l'a fait après ce que
c'est c'est beaucoup quand tu y as yahia
de l'activité en plein air et ils sont
très vite essoufflé aurélie elle souffre
des logis vasculaire de la face une
maladie chronique qui selon elle
s'aggrave en fonction des pics de
pollution et ça me crée beaucoup de mecs
us du coup je pars ali g 1 le syndrome
bernard horner et sikhs et elle est
rouge et je saigne du nez aussi et je
ferme tout et je suis je peux rester six
heures accroché à ma bouteille d'oxygène
aurélie comme son fils ne sont pas les
seuls à souffrir de la pollution dans la
vallée mallory guillon est médecin
généraliste troubles respiratoires et
orl sont au menu quotidiennement dans
son cabinet pour le médecin
pas de doute il y à une corrélation
entre ces pathologies et la pollution de
la vallée il ya énormément d'études sur
effectivement les impacts sanitaires
delà de l'atmosphère des particules
fines de l'atmosphère on sait très bien
que ça a un impact pulmonaire on sait
que les particules fines avec le carbone
suie et puis effectivement
malheureusement maintenant on a on a
aussi découvert qu'ils avaient des
oxydants voilà dans les particules fines
en fait on sait très bien que ça a une
affinité avec le tissu pulmonaire
donc ça a créé l'inflammation
malheureusement au pire même des fois ça
peut créer malheureusement des cancers
pulmonaires pour alerter mais aussi pour
agir
mallory guillon a cofondé avec muriel au
prince le collectif colère pure en 2018
pour évaluer le niveau de pollution de
la vallée le groupe a réalisé de
nombreuses analyses en septembre dernier
les cheveux de 76 enfants et six adultes
ont été analysés résultat des métaux
lourds mais aussi des terres rares ont
été retrouvés avec des niveaux de
toxicité chronique pour le collectif
c'est tout un cocktail de polluants qui
encercle cette vallée très encaissée à
deux pas du mont blanc
en fait il faudrait pas du tout de fons
de pollution ici dans ce fonds de
vallées et en fait c'est là où il ya le
plus de sources de pollution qui sont
donc importantes
vous avez ici une usine qui traite le
carbone vous avez un incinérateur qu'on
a placé ici en fond de vallée donc là où
il n'y a pas d'air vous êtes sur les
polluants reste un incinérateur fait
2000 molécules chimiques au minimum et
vous avez une autoroute qui monte à
chamonix l'a40 où il y a alors selon les
jours c'est entre 1800 et 2000 500
camions jour plus le chauffage l'hiver
aussi bien le chauffage au bois que le
chauffage au fuel qui est aussi très
polluants qui fait que du coup aller
voilà tout les polluent la pollution
stagne parce que vous avez aussi la
version des températures l'hiver ou en
fait ça fait un couvercle alors là elles
sont piégés ça peut pas s'échapper en
2012 un ppa un plan de protection de
l'atmosphère a été adoptée renouvelée en
2019 il comprend des mesures visant à
réduire les émissions de particules
fines
le collectif de son côté souhaite avant
tout être écoutés et demande des mesures
plus fortes comme par exemple la
gratuité des transports en commun lors
des pics de pollution restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur les propos de la maire écologiste de
poitiers elle estime que l'aérien
doit plus faire partie des rêves de nos
enfants une mesure nécessaire une énième
polémique nous en parlerons avec nos
invités
et puis direction israël où benyamin
nétanyahou se défend après les attaques
de la procureure lors de la reprise de
son procès pour corruption
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec une jambe ont mangé un autre combat
on ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
et
[Musique]
la france a développé depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale une capacité militaire
de défense et de projection elle est la
première puissance de l'union européenne
tant par le niveau d'investissement que
par la capacité opérationnelle
mais depuis dix ans pour rattraper son
retard
allemagne augmenter son budget deux fois
plus vite que la france nous avons
beaucoup de projets industriels et
capacités en commun mais il faut
reconnaître qu'en matière d'armement les
allemands ne sont pas des partenaires
très solide
il existe des divergences fondamentales
entre les ambitions militaires de la
france et celle de l'allemagne
à force de nous regarder avec
satisfaction
nous ne voyons pas ce qui se passe chez
nos voisins de la france pourrait perdre
son leadership au sein de l'union
européenne dans le domaine de la défense
conventionnelle
dès cette année
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez en
france cette nouvelle polémique après
les propos de la maire europe ecologie
les verts de poitiers léonore montcuq
lui veut supprimer une partie des
subventions accordées à 3 aéroclub les
avions ne doit plus faire rêver les
enfants at elle ajouté ce qui a provoqué
pas mal de réactions à commencer par la
classe politique pour l'écouter je me
suis toujours engagé dans l'écologie
justement pour pouvoir offrir aux
enfants des rêves à la fois désirable
est à la fois responsable pour l'avenir
donc on ne peut absolument pas m'accuser
de vouloir remettre en question les
rêves d'enfants
alors le réveil rien nos chères têtes
blondes doivent-ils l'abandonner au nom
de l'écologie la mesure de la maire
écologiste et l audible ou est ce une
énième polémique autour d'un maire
europe ecologie les verts l'élu outre
pastel ses droits c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
guillaume gontard sénateurs europe
écologie et les verts de l'isère laurent
jacot bélie porte parole rn bonsoir à
tous les deux messieurs merci d'être
avec nous d'avoir accepté ce face à face
guy roux gontard votre collègue la maire
de poitiers collègue de parti on va dire
notre passe-t-elle pas son rôle d'élu
que de nous dicter les rêves de nos
enfants comment vous avez réagi vous à
cette sortie vous avoir juste que c'est
un petit peu fatigant et quasi polimique
20 jours et voilà je pense que on a des
sujets beaucoup beaucoup plus important
comment j'ai réagi l'ensemble des
communes actuellement des collectivités
vote vote leur budget et sont en train
de de faire de la politique et de
réfléchir effectivement à comment on
attribue d'aidés et subventions à telle
ou telle association ça se passe dans
l'ensemble des collectivités la poitiers
avec elle et aux normes ont conduit à
fait a fait ce choix là en plus il faut
il faut remettre les choses à leur place
je crois que c'est trois ou quatre mille
euros de subventions sur un gros club
qui a un budget depuis trois cent mille
2 puis 3 200 mille euros
et donc oui les haut-normands conduit
son équipe ont fait ce choix là de dire
eh ben oui il faut faire rêver et faut
faire rêver les enfants et la meilleure
moyen qui avaient des enfants c'est leur
permettent de pouvoir partir en vacances
c'est de mettre une vraie politique pour
que l'ensemble des enfants puissent
partir en vacances tant des enfants de
de poitiers puis notamment voir la mer
et de privilégier ce type de politique
donc tout simplement la maire écologiste
de poitiers a fait acte de politique a
fait son travail de maire et moi je
trouve ça particulièrement bien et est
bien sûr aussi en amenant travaillant
sur cette question de la transition
écologique qui est le le mal de notre
siècle ce ce combat contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est ce qui
doit tout ce nous nous animer
aujourd'hui laurent jacot bedie pour
vous
finalement elle a tapé juste aux non
d'écologie on doit arrêter de rêver d
avion parce que guillaume au contraire
nous dit oui ce n'est qu'une subvention
mais c'est vrai que ce qui a provoqué la
polémique ce n'est pas finalement le
de subventions c'est la phrase qui est
l'évêque voler en gros il faut arrêter
de rêver d'avion pour nos enfants c'est
pas la bonne solution votre réaction
laurent jacobellis
écoutez je pense que ce n'est pas le
rôle du politique de décider ce à quoi
nous avons le droit de rêver ou de ne
pas rêver surtout lorsqu'il s'agit des
enfants
je rappelle que cet aérodrome recevait
notamment des enfants gravement malades
pour qui la lueur d'espoir le p'tit
bonheur c'était de faire un tour en
avion et bien une mère dogmatique
idéologique a décidé de casser leur rêve
ils empêchent les enfants de rêver comme
il les empêche d'ailleurs les adultes de
vivre ces merveilles c'est finalement
une étape supplémentaire après une
longue série
le maire de lyon qui refusent que les
enfants mangent de la viande à table
dans le pays de la gastronomie
le maire de bordeaux qui refuse que l'on
est des sapins de noël dans les rues
parce qu'ils y voient un arbre mort là
où nous on voit une fête familiale une
fête religieuse qui unit les français ce
sont ceux qui veulent arrêter le tour de
france qui plutôt que de voir une belle
épreuve sportive qui fait le tour de
notre beau pays voir un symbole machiste
et polluants ces gens détestent la vie
ces gens détestent notre mode de vie est
derrière la façade écologistes se cache
et dogmatique qui veulent imposer la
vision d'une minorité à la majorité il
n'ya rien d'écologique là dedans et je
pense que les pires ennemis de
l'écologie c'est le groupe europe
ecologie les verts qui font détester
l'écologie alors que l'écologie devrait
faire rêver l'écologie devrait être un
progrès un projet optimiste de progrès
et bien avec eux c'est la régression
l'interdiction la taxe est la punition
je pense qu'il ya pas pire écologistes
que et on vend par vatra réponse oui
c'est voilà je peux dire quand on a leur
assemblée nationale qui n'a pas l'ombre
d'une idée sur justement ce qu'il
faudrait mettre en place pour le
réchauffement climatique par exemple
voilà le type le type de réponse bien
sûr qu'on a des élus qui font de la
politique et aux heureusement je dirais
que les mères
d'un politique quand vos amis
subventionne largement la fête du cochon
plutôt que la diversité culturelle
il me semble qu'ils font de la politique
de la politique et ça devrait d'ailleurs
faire faire polémique sur moi je
voudrais revenir sur le sur le rêve des
sur le rêve des enfants parce qu'on met
des milliards pour façonner le rêve des
enfants depuis leur plus jeune âge donc
moi je donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui
font des polémiques sur la question de
la publicité on a la voix qui m'a
actuellement la loi climat a minima
justement on voit bien qu'on n'a pas de
réponse même de la part de la règle sur
cette question du réchauffement du
réchauffement climatique mais on a
plusieurs amendements je sais pas si
c'est les collègues députés si si marine
le pen a voté
c'est un moment il ya eu des amendements
justement pour interdire la publicité
pour limiter la publicité à la fois sur
sur les vieux objets les plus polluants
mais aussi pour limiter la publicité
envers les enfants pour justement leur
laisser cette liberté donc moi j'espère
que c'est que ces amendements seront
votées en tout cas nous on en déposera
également au sénat et on verra si toutes
ces donneurs de leçons et ben passe à
l'application et laisse rêver nos
enfants sapin à noël tour de france vous
l'avez dit menus sans viande
je vous propose avant nous faire réagir
l'orangé comédie d' écouter la réponse
de l'europe écologie les verts julien
bayou poitiers énième polémique où
l'enjeu semble surtout d'attaquer les
écologistes autour de monconduit d'être
ciblé soutien et courage à elle que le
gouvernement se concentre sur ses
responsabilités plutôt que d'échanger
ses éléments de langage avec l'extrême
droite à l'orangé comédie clairement
vous êtes ciblées à la fin de de cette
réaction 1 qui cible une certaine
manière le
le rn qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cette défense d'ailleurs la même que
guillaume monta alors d'abord je ne me
sens pas visé puisqu'il parle d'extrême
droite et que je suis pas parole d'un
mouvement qui est le rassemblement
national qui ne fait pas partie de cette
famille politique là mais quoi qu'il en
soit je veux bien répondre à la question
j'ai entendu de notre interlocuteur il
ya quelques instants qu'il a fait des
propositions il ya eu quatre fois le mot
interdire qui est revenu vous voyez nous
nous avons une vision de l'écologie qui
est différente nous voulons investir
investir dans l'hydrogène investir dans
les technologies du futur l'avion du
futur plutôt que de l'interdire et nous
voulons aussi créer plus d'emplois grâce
au localisme le localisme c'est produire
près de chez nous ça permet de contrôler
la qualité des productions et ça permet
de ne pas faire venir du bout du monde
des objets ou des produits agricoles
qu'on pourrait faire ici et donc de
moins polluer mais vous voyez ça c'est
une écologie positive une écologie qui
créent de l'emploi et les crée une
écologie de l'avenir c'est pas
l'écologie qui empêche de vivre mais
surtout vous savez l'écologie pour
europe ecologie les verts c'est un
masque ce sous un thème fédérateur
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique protéger la faune et la flore
et bien sous ce thème fédérateur ils ont
des idéologies un peu plus nauséabondes
comme par exemple l'islamo gauchisme je
rappellerai qu'à strasbourg
la maire écologiste vient de signer veut
fait signer un chèque de deux millions
et demi pour une mosquée islamistes
inféodés à erdogan
c'est à dire qu'ils veulent importer
l'insécurité l'islamisation de la
société dans notre pays
plutôt que de faire rêver les enfants
voilà qui se cache derrière le masque de
l'écologie alors valérie pécresse s'en
aller complètement dans vos propos à
condamner durement aussi c'est pas en
tout cas de la maire de poitiers je vous
propose de l'écouter avant de vous faire
réagir games compte à poitiers aéroclub
voilà le modèle de société que veut nous
imposer les maires eux élevé priver les
enfants de leur rêve et les rééduquer
ce n'est plus de l'écologie c'est du
totalitarisme du totalitarisme elle va
assez loin aussi valérie
p13 et je rejoins les critiques de
laurent jacobellis guillon gontard les
électeurs en votant vert est ce qu'ils
ont vraiment voté pour ce type de mesure
on parle de cette aéro club n'en parle
effectivement de deuxième mosquée à
strasbourg justement de quoi de quoi on
parle exactement parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est interdit c'est
juste d'une subvention et d'un choix
politique effectivement qu'il n'a pas
été attribués
quand même à un aéroclub donc quand même
voilà je veux dire qui peut aller aller
au club et faire de l'avion ces
campagnes c'est quand même pas monsieur
et madame tout le monde d'accord donc de
quoi on parle et on parle de lui d'une
mère de de poitiers qui décide quoi qui
décide elle
al'inverse de permettre à l'ensemble des
enfants de sa ville de pouvoir aller en
colonie de vacances
voilà effectivement ce que c'est
l'écologie très clairement à lyon c'est
mettre en place le rsa jeunes à grenoble
ou dans d'autres villes
c'est travailler sur l'alimentation
passée à 100% de côté de cantine bio
c'est travailler sur les transports
c'est travailler sur la mise en place et
sur le fait qu' on est des trains de
nuit parce que je le disais à monsieur
pour moi l'avion du futur
ça passera plainte le train de nuit ça
passe par le développement du
ferroviaire
ça passe par le développement du fret
donc oui on a des idées et qui sont
clairement positives je pense pas avoir
prononcé une seule fois le mot interdit
au contraire moi je suis réaliste je
suis pragmatique je sais qu'on a une
échéance qu'on ne peut pas attendre que
les 4 degrés qui nous sont annoncés ils
sont réels et que on doit se battre pour
ça justement pour que nos enfants
puissent continuer à rêver et c'est
comme ça qu'on travaillera et moi je
suis fier de tous les élus écologistes
du pôle écologiste dans toutes les
villes de france se bat et mettent en
place ces mesures qui sonneront
justement l'avenir de nos enfants
et c'est ce que ne fait pas le
gouvernement c'est ce que ne fait pas ce
monsieur est ce ce que fait pas ce que
ne font pas ses ennemis à ces critiques
la laurent jats comédie qu'est ce que
vous répondez vous fait pas grand chose
aux arènes sur l'écologie et bien
attendez que nous nous soyons pouvoir et
vous verrez qu'avec le localisme
notamment nous ferons beaucoup de choses
mais nous arrêterons avec les lubies
écologistes c'est à dire que l'énergie
qui polluent le moins aujourd'hui c'est
le nucléaire les écologistes
rêve de l'arrêter pour les remplacer par
des centrales à charbon qui polluent
énormément ou pour les remplacer par des
éoliennes inefficace et qui au final ont
un impact négatif sur la planète
vous parliez de l'avenir des enfants
protéger l'avenir des enfants monsieur
ce n'est pas comme le maire de lyon qui
refusent d'armes et la police municipale
et qui laisse la ville en coupe réglée
prises par les dealers l'avenir de nos
enfants monsieur ce ne sont pas des
mosquées liste la liste pour que demain
ils préfèrent la charia la charia la loi
de la république vous voyez on n'a pas
la même vision de l'avenir de nos
enfants nous nous les laisserons rêver
nous les laisserons goûter au plaisir de
la joie de noël et nous laissons les
familles aller à la fête du cochon que
vous évoquez à hayange chez mon ami
fabien engelmann ou dans des traditions
très anciennes qui était bien avant lui
d'ailleurs les gens se retrouvent pour
faire la fête
chanter danser autour de la gastronomie
vous comprenez ça les plaisirs de la vie
ce à quoi vous voulez nous faire
renoncer
eh bien vous n'y arriverez pas votre
écologie punitive nous n'en voulons pas
et nous voulons une écologie optimiste
guillaume montard vous assumez voilà les
décisions de votre collègue de parti
les maires de poitiers yannick jadot un
candidat à la présidentielle europe
ecologie les verts en 2022 lui est un
peu plus nuancé 1 voilà il apparaît
quand même de maladresse il a peur quand
même de perdre une partie de son
électorat
avec ce type de polémique yannick jadot
selon vous non je pense qu'on perd
jamais son électro en faisant ce qu'il
faut faire justement pour l'avenir de
nos enfants
donc moi j'ai aucun souci là-dessus je
pense que pour répondre à monsieur moi
aussi j'aime j'aime bien dit j'aime bien
mangé j'ai aucun souci là-dessus et je
pense que l'ensemble des écologistes
mais peut-être ce qui nous différencie
c'est que moi j'ai envie de pouvoir
vivre de pouvoir manger de pouvoir
rigoler encore très longtemps et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on agit et vous dites
attendons qu'on soit pouvoir eh bien
nous on n'attend pas d'où on a on agit
concrètement directement dans chaque
commune et dans chaque petit village moi
j'ai été un maire d'un petit village et
j'ai agi concrètement et vous pouvez
vous pouvez venir enfin je conçois vous
serez très bien accueillis mais en tout
cas nous on sait faire la fête
et donc on n'a pas besoin de conseils
par rapport par rapport à ça voilà et et
7 cette polémique je sais pas je pense
que demain il y en aura une autre il y
en aura une autre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en fait c'est
juste que bah oui on est peut-être le
parti qui dérange pourquoi parce que on
est les réalistes on et les pragmatiques
on est ce qui avons la réponse à cette
échéance qui nous attend ne pas passer
au dessus des 2 degrés on a vu les
jeunes qui sont dans la rue qui nous
demande
agissez agissent et agissez il voit bien
que ça ne marche pas au niveau du
gouvernement
ils voient bien que c'est pas les
parties que monsieur qui vont amener des
réponses
nous on a ses réponses on agit
localement qui les jours et moi je suis
fier de ça je reviens et ce sera le mot
de la fin laurent jacobellis à yannick
jadot le le chef entre guillemets
d'europe écologie les verts qui
appellent d'ailleurs à réunir les
dirigeants de de la gauche c'est quelque
chose quand même que vous craignez au
rassemblement national pour la prochaine
présidentielle je rappelle qu europe
ecologie les verts ont de plus tôt bons
scores notamment aux européennes dernier
vous voulez craignez vous craignez cette
union ah non pas du tout vous savez la
démocratie c'est que chacun puisse se
présenter avec son programme et avec
l'union qu'il souhaite on ne les craint
pas non non pas du tout c'est
l'expression démocratique normal mais je
pense qu'ils auront du mal à expliquer
qu'ils vont lutter contre le
réchauffement de la planète
en interdisant les sapins de noël ou en
interdisant la viande à l'école vous
savez on a l'impression qu'il ya un
concours lépine de la mesure la plus
absurde
chez les écologistes je vous en cite une
qui vous fera probablement rire c'est
une fois encore à strasbourg une
conseillère municipale a demandé à ce
qu'on arrête de rendre plus propre les
rues et des appartements en attend en
attaque en panne il errani les punaises
de lit parce que eux aussi avaient le
droit de vivre et qu'il n'avait pas de
logement qu'il fallait qu'on apprenne à
cohabiter avec eux quand on arrive à ce
niveau d'absurdité à ce niveau de
volonté de de mal-être de l'être humain
eh bien je pense qu'on est plus audible
et je ne comprends pas
du tout que vous à payer encore europe
ecologie les verts assumer que vous êtes
aujourd'hui un groupe d'ultragauche qui
a d'autres ambitions
mais ne faites pas croire aux français
qu'en construisant des mosquées
islamistes on défendra la nature
personne ne vous croit le mot de la fin
quand même rapidement guingamp tard vous
êtes un groupe d'ultragauche
bon écoute et ccc encore des polémiques
j'ai entendu la polémique sur les
punaises de lit ce que je disais
peut-être qu'on peut se la garder pour
la semaine prochaine
si jamais on est en mal de polémiques on
pourra on pourra la ressortir août et je
pense qu'il faut être juste un petit peu
un petit peu sérieux je dirais que dans
notre pays quand même
quand j'écoute quand j'écoute monsieur
on a eu la taille du conseil régional
d'occitanie par action française
quelques jours après le saccage des
librairies à lyon par des identitaires
on a les loups blancs turcs eux contre
les kurdes et les arméniens il ya
avant-hier on a des des représentants
nazi dans l'armée française je pense que
oui à certaines inquiétudes et je pense
qu'on devrait se poser effectivement les
bonnes questions
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté le jeu du face à face à
guillaume gontard laurent jacot belli
avec deux visions du monde effectivement
qui semble en tout cas se pose et merci
à vous deux et à bientôt sur rt france
merci à vous
la réponse de benyamin nétanyahou qui ne
s'est pas fait attendre il dénonce une
affirmation hypocrite une chasse aux
sorcières le premier ministre israélien
qui répond aux attaques de la procureure
lors de la reprise de son procès pour
corruption dans la matinée elle accuse
d'avoir usé de son pouvoir de façon
illégitime mallet me netanyahu poursuivi
dans trois affaires cela n'a pas empêché
son parti le likoud de remporté les
dernières élections législatives
une courte victoire sans majorité
conséquence le président israélien
entame aujourd'hui des consultations en
vue de désigner un candidat pour former
le prochain gouvernement un procès qui
rompt donc incertain l'avenir politique
du premier ministre emil boc h
plusieurs charges pèsent contre le
premier ministre israélien âgé de 71 ans
benyamin netanyahu est accusée de
corruption fraude et abus de confiance
dans trois affaires différentes
il aurait reçu plus de 180000 euros de
cadeaux de la part d'hommes d'affaires
en échange de faveurs financières ou
personnel la justice le soupçonne aussi
d'avoir accordé des avantages aux
patrons de bezeq un opérateur israélien
de télécommunications contre une
couverture médiatique favorable à la
reprise de son procès ce lundi la
procureur principal l'a accusé d'avoir
abusé de son pouvoir
il a usé de façon illégitime du grand
pouvoir gouvernemental qui lui est
conférée entre autres pour demander et
obtenir des avantages injustifiés de
propriétaires de médias importants en
israël pour favoriser ses intérêts
personnels notamment quand il voulait se
faire réélire des accusations contestées
depuis le début du procès par benyamin
nétanyahou fch en marge de cette
nouvelle audience
partisans et opposants au premier
ministre étaient rassemblés devant le
tribunal pour le soutenir ou demander
son départ
je pense que nous assistons au début de
la fin pour netanyahu il comprendra
enfin qu'il doit partir mais il ne veut
pas partir alors peut-être que le
tribunal lui montrera que c'est fini et
qu'il doit quitter son poste
nous soutenons le premier ministre qui
travaillent jour et nuit pour l'état
d'israël
vous ne pouvez changer un premier
ministre que par des élections
nous ne laisserons pas cela se produire
d'aucune autre façon cette nouvelle
audience arrive quelques semaines après
les élections législatives
à l'issue du scrutin du 23 mars le
likoud parti du premier ministre est
arrivé en tête
un résultat qui ne lui assure pas pour
autant la majorité nécessaire pour
former un gouvernement stable et rend
l'avenir politique du premier ministre
un certain au pouvoir depuis 15 ans
benyamin nétanyahou est le premier chef
de gouvernement à être jugé pendant
l'exercice de ses fonctions
ça demande d'immunité a été refusée par
le parlement ont commencé déroulée
l'audience aujourd'hui quel impact aura
le procès sur la formation d'un
gouvernement éléments de réponse avec
paula slayer journalistes pour rt
internationale cela fait maintenant plus
d'un an que de telles accusations sont
échangés selon le premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou ses détracteurs mène
une chasse aux sorcières voir un push il
dit que ses accusateurs tente de
l'écarter du pouvoir
dans le même temps pour les opposants de
benyamin nétanyahou
il est en train de mener une sorte de
coup d'état ou gouvernementales contre
les accusations auxquelles il est
confronté
benyamin nétanyahou est serré de
délégitimer le résultat du procès et
voudrait avoir une forme de pouvoir
absolu sur l'état d'israël
certains craignent qu'il ne puisse pas
se concentrer sur la gestion du pays une
fois a pris par le procès et que réélu
premier ministre il pourrait trouver un
moyen de stopper la procédure judiciaire
cette affaire pourrait également salir
la réputation du système judiciaire il
serait aujourd'hui l'ex pdg de vale à un
média israélien a témoigné selon lui le
premier ministre mettait une telle
pression sur va là qu'il avait reçu le
sobriquet de kim jong-il et cette
pression pour recevoir une couverture
médiatique positive l'a aidé ou les
élections et dans l'opinion publique
il devrait y avoir d'autres témoignages
similaires dans la suite du procès dans
les jours à venir
les consultations permettent d'établir
qui est en mesure de former un
gouvernement de coalition a party loi
remporté 71 sièges sur les 120 de la
knesset
c'est à dire le parlement les
consultations entre les différents
parkings ont commencé malgré le procès
de benyamin nétanyahou et certains
partis notamment à droite du spectre
politique chasse par exemple où le parti
likoud de benyamin nétanyahou l'ont déjà
recommandé pour être le prochain premier
ministre ne ternira il est très peu
probable que le procès influence l'issue
de ces consultations il y à déjà plus
d'un an la cour suprême d'israël a
déclaré que le procès n'avait pas de
conséquence sur le gouvernement à venir
et les consultations
cette déclaration de la cour suprême
aura toujours du poids aujourd'hui
et puis cela n'aura pas d'effet sur les
consultations et pour être franc si les
parties ne se préoccupe pas vraiment des
procès les opposant à benyamin
nétanyahou essaie de le tourner à leur
avantage et les partisans de légna me
netanyahu font exactement la même chose
mais cela ne va pas vraiment influencé
le résultat des consultations et semble
très improbable que benyamin nétanyahou
réussir à former un goût
demant le président israélien reuven
rivlin a rencontré aujourd'hui les
différents partis politiques ce qui est
la coutume en israël il rencontre les
différents partis et leurs demandes
qu'il recommande comme premier ministre
il a lancé le processus est rien est
arrivé selon la constitution israélienne
il n'est pas obligatoire de demander aux
parties qui a fait le plus de voix mais
est recommandé de demander aux parties
le plus susceptible de former un
gouvernement de coalition
à ce stade il semble que ce parti sera
celui de benyamin nétanyahou il devrait
donc proposer à benyamin nétanyahou de
tentes est le premier de former un
gouvernement de coalition
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
emilie goût gages quant à moi j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20
heures
[Musique]
les trente ans que les cours sont
manipulés comment est-ce qu'on peut
réguler ça on ne peut pas c'est une
manipulation on va dire 2 0 la
possibilité de cette manipulation est
encore plus facile parce que vous avez
de nouveaux traders parce que vous avez
des gens qui ont été attirés par
l'argent assez facile le bitcoin
illustre quelque chose qui existe de
toute éternité gagner de l'argent en ne
faisant rien en achetant un actif qui
nous vaut intrinsèquement rien grâce à
des gogos qui n'y comprennent rien sauf
la promesse de faire fortune qui en
profitent réellement que ces
manipulations pour malheureusement c'est
pas les petites sardines cd requinque le
petit particulier il est là pour se
faire tondre
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à bagdad alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour l'étudier dernière
fois que la france était en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge aussi me
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage à
très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous